for much of star wars visual media the
focus has been predominantly on people
whose last name is skywalker
even with shows like the clone wars
animated series which introduced fans to
a young padawan by the name of ahsoka
tano
anakin's exploits were always front and
center with the mandalorian creators
have a chance to explore a side of the
star wars universe
that's often gone ignored over the years
the fate of the galaxy isn't in the
balance
instead the plot follows a mandalorian
by the name of din jaron whose tasks
were delivering a child back to its
people
as the pair travel to far off planet
audiences are introduced to characters
and creatures we've never heard of
before
for two episodes so far in season two
audiences have had a chance to spend
time with captain carson teva
as played by paul sun young lee like
most actors would be
lee is ecstatic to be part of this
universe as he said in an interview with
cbc news
a korean canadian in the star wars
universe gives hope to a lot of people
that dreams do come true
that this is attainable that star wars
in a nutshell for me
lee had a long history before landing
one of his biggest roles to date on the
mandalorian
if you're interested in checking out the
rest of his filmography then you have a
lot of catching up to do
paul seung young lee's acting career
stretches back over three decades
beginning in 1989 back in the day he was
credited as simply paul lee
and made numerous one-off appearances on
a variety of television programs
such as total recall 2070 soul food
and duck millennials may recognize the
actor as bruno hong fat
in the 1996 film harriet the spy lee saw
his career break out in a big way
when he was cast in the canadian soap
opera train 48
these starred in 256 episodes of the
series which ran
from 2003 to 2005 and followed the lives
of 12 commuters
and their interactions on their train to
work lee played randy coe a
mild-mannered engineer
as well as a science fiction enthusiast
we learned that he was dumbed by his
fiancee
but he soon enters another relationship
with liz another one of the commuters
however their relationship also
ultimately fails when she decides to
conceive a child
via artificial insemination the show may
have ended but it was just the start of
an extremely prolific career
train 48 wouldn't be the last time you
see paul's son young lee on canadian
television
he also made appearances on series like
1-800 missing
and billable hours however if you are a
teenager around 2010 then chances are
good you recognize him best for his role
as joan tong
on degrassi the next generation more
based out of canada the series saw
immense success across the border in the
united states
teenagers on the program had to deal
with a host of taboo issues
such as bullying teen pregnancy and body
image issues
fortunately lee managed to stay away
from those kinds of problems
as juwon tong he was the owner of little
mistakes which employed some of the kids
at degrassi high
he appeared in six episodes spanning
across seasons 10
and 11. after that lee starred in tv
series like almost heroes and shoot the
messenger
he also had a small role in the 2014
robocop reboot
but it was all leading up to a prominent
role with which netflix subscribers are
all too familiar
kim's convenience may have debuted on
canadian television but it's become a
hit with audiences all over the globe
ever since it hit netflix lee plays kim
san gil
patriarch of the family running a
convenience store in a toronto
neighborhood he is traditional when it
comes to his korean roots which means he
can be stubborn at times but
ultimately just wants what's best for
his family he has an estranged
relationship with his son
junk shang chi but they gradually work
on making it better throughout the
series
all four seasons are now available to
watch on netflix and fans can look
forward to plenty more kim's convenience
in the years to come cbc announced
earlier in 2020 that the show was picked
up for two more seasons no release date
has been announced for the new episodes
which may well be held up by covert 19
restrictions
via tv series finale but sooner or later
you'll be able to see appa back at it
again
as captain carson teva lee's reaching
his biggest audience yet
hopefully it won't be the last time he
ventures into major blockbuster
properties
because he brings a natural gravitas to
this larger-than-life universe
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one